it put the stethoscope on his head and
that's somehow giving me an
ekg of his heart what is happening
[Music]
dr mike plays one star games
on the apple itunes store that are sort
of medically
relevant medical
game okay we got a medical trivia game
with three stars but i feel like three
stars are still above average so we need
something a little bit worse than that
oh
okay i found one it's real doctor
simulator virtual hospital game
two stars 191 ratings and it's age four
plus so you know i'm good and the
description reads
take care of the patients and help them
get better
in their health while they are in their
hospital
so far it's running pretty flawlessly
whoa
an aggressive child and
mom running off of a roof oh
jason is just fell off the roof hurry
up and take him to the hospital jason
is just fell off the roof the gate
doesn't even fit the screen
i can't even click the next button hold
on maybe on the bottom
i got it okay i get to control the
ambulance look at that
driving forward you know it'd be great
if i knew which way i had to go
look at that i just pulled right into
the hospital just by driving straight
oh my god it has like a joystick and
everything
and who is this random person walking
him look at this random gentleman
sitting here hello sir
oh look i can freely walk through you
because you're not an actual character
in this game
i'm gonna walk this way level complete
no joke what happened to jason next
my son fell off the roof a few minutes
ago we should hurry and take him to
x-ray room to assess
bone fractures oh come on i can't even
see i can't even walk out of the room
this is ridiculous i can walk through
furniture but i can't walk out the door
how do i report a glitch to the
developers
[Music]
oh i think i did it yes i got him out of
the room
the funniest part about this is look at
the caretaker that's
look at this caretaker that's taking him
around this caretaker looks so
he's walking like this with the patient
why is that
the wheels on the wheelchair aren't even
spinning
this app is so solid that when i pause
the game
it put the main screen of the game above
the pause screen so i can't even start
the game back up
i'm switching i can't i quit alright
searching for another
horrible game baby born surgery
one and a half stars with 255 reviews
but get this it's a baby born surgery
game with the sub category
action now it's a quick download i
wonder why
cesarean birth with a very
red haired looking elegant woman
who seems to be a nurse because she has
a heart on her head
and a baby that looks like an adult
let's go play
mark accompanied uncomfortable wife lisa
came to the hospital
a month away from the pre-production
stomach pain so that lisa is very upset
confused mark is very nervous
this is something only a doctor would
notice it says
operation room and underneath it says
pull
you would never have an or with a pull
because then if you wash your hands and
you become sterile
how are you gonna pull the doorknob it
has to be push only so you can push and
lean into it
warning don't try this at home thanks
with a house on fire
logo it's bleeding not cheese bleeding
it's bleeding you'd better u-e-s
the gauze to stop it hold on a second
time i'm calling time
out on this game what is going on with
that heart rhythm on the left side
this patient is going into v-fib and
is essentially dead and i need to shock
this patient perform cpr
if you're gonna be medically accurate
you can't show that rhythm to me and
expect me to be okay with it i'm not
okay with this rhythm this is brutal i'm
leaving this game
back on the app store looking for a gym
oh my god
there's a game called crazy toenail
doctor oh my god can i just click on it
i'm not gonna download it because i
if i put this app on my phone i feel
like
i don't know the government's gonna
start spying on me or something because
oh my god look at this
you can shop you can do x-rays
you can even share your toenails on
facebook
okay i found another winner it
technically has two plus stars but it
looks so bad that i want to try it
dr mania i knows dental
i don't know where it's going but i'm
excited
it was easy and they have the same
problems
also the girls made moaning sounds it's
not appropriate
well great perfect for youtube the
images of the children in this game are
very graphic
my two-year-old was screaming in fear
looking at my phone
play um i guess let's pick dexter
okay dexter looks sick um
i would love for it to give me some
instructions
maybe a thermometer
what do i do with it though put it in
his mouth
what is with the moaning noises oh 100
degrees fahrenheit
technically not yet a fever a fever
starts at 100.3
so that's okay let's listen to his heart
[Music]
his heart sounds good next his blood
pressure
that's an interesting sound for a blood
pressure cuff
[Music]
oh my god how do i measure his blood
pressure
[Music]
but just skip the rest of that blood
pressure exam what is this
what it put the stethoscope on his head
[Music]
and that's somehow giving me an ekg of
his heart
with the worst rhythm i've ever seen
what is happening what is this
[Music]
what is what is happening here what
there's a what looks like to be an air
pressure gun like when you go to the car
wash and they have those hoses
[Music]
i don't understand why is it blowing him
is this a sponge
oh it's an ice pack for the head
i gave him an injection i don't even
know what i'm injecting into this poor
child
the patient is not cured use the tools
to fully heal your patient
some of it is pretty shady like this
child moans and the fact that i have to
use an
air hose to somehow fix him what in the
world does that mean i'm going to scroll
down just because i want to get to the
bottom of this
i want to get to the bottom of the
bottom like i don't even want to look at
these top rated games
oh i got a good one it's called hospital
surgery doctor game
so you know it's good and it's made by
fat lion productions
choose a case well there's only one case
cage details left leg i love the case
details just left leg
nothing else two minutes and 58 seconds
and then it'll pay 103
i didn't need to know how much money i
was going to make on this operation i
was riding my bike and i said see mom no
hands
and that is that i'm gonna go ahead and
say that's a really bad
history click on a body part to select
it
and there is a female patient in her bra
and panties
now you need to find out if the patient
needs simple treatment
or do you need to replace the organ left
foot is only 72 percent
you know when a patient comes into my
office and their left foot at 72
that's when i start thinking should i
amputate left
side leg
[Music]
what in the world is a left side leg
what's a left side leg drag your finger
over the part
to fix it oh
look at this this is like magic i get to
rub the foot
and it gets healed oh boom and patient
treated to become the best surgeon you
need equipments
do i this gentleman difficulty two
hospital crosses area abdomen click on a
body part to select it
big intestine pelvis
65 first of all i don't know what organ
i just highlighted but
that is not his pelvis i saw a kung fu
master break brick using his hands and i
tried something that i wasn't supposed
to do at home
these are absolutely awful am i sweating
as you can tell that was quite stressful
for me and my diplomas back here weren't
able
are you starting this again because you
know what happened in the amateur
surgery video
what
we're going to do this on camera we're
going to do this on we're going to do
this on camera
it's here for dec it's not even real
click here
in the section where there used to be a
plant and enjoy these games
as always stay happy and healthy
[Music]